whenever private pile
I will not punish him I will punish all
of you yep there we go the DI and the
drill sergeant is going to definitely
Dole out punishment as a mass punishment
I'm command sergeant major retired
Lamont Christian I served about 11 years
as a drill sergeant and then as a senior
leader in organizations that conducted
basic combat training today we're going
to be looking at boot camp scenes and
seeing how realistic they are and always
answer every question with yes drill
sergeant
the standard for responding to a drill
sergeant is yes drill sergeant no drill
sergeant and if it has to have an
affirmative response then the whole
platoon will sound just like that in 10
hours that's what she spends on game
Tundra sergeant Jesus Christ
this is a new company record the drill
sergeant was so impressed because you
know in the early part of training it's
a challenge for somebody who perhaps has
not handled the weapon before what we
would call weapons training to be able
to take that weapon apart put it back
together and do what you saw for us do
there which was that functions check
what your hope is as a DI or drill
sergeant is that everybody in there can
do it like for us
shrimp and potatoes shrimp burger what's
funny is when they're in there with them
with toothbrushes that's something of
the past there was times where uh you
know you give a recruit scissors and say
go cut the grass they're Foster in this
environment of working together as a
team which you saw with the weapons
training which is what I call Mindless
repetition just do it over and over and
over again until you get it right that
has the same training effect that this
used to have the approach that the drill
sergeant had in here was very very
common for that time period during the
Vietnam war so that's about a nine
when you look at uh obstacle courses
usually in boot camp you'll go through
them twice obstacle courses are really
designed to find your upper body
strength and also determine your
endurance and so it may even test your
fear of heights
um fear of darkness and then you get to
actually experience the teamwork helping
each other you saw that a couple of
times in there and definitely that
screaming and yellings often we call it
simulating you know Battlefield
conditions
this is the rabbit hole the rabbit comes
out of his hole what is interesting is
ropes and not tying is no longer taught
in basic training it is in Ranger school
though you're actually tested in the
mountain phase as things uh change over
time there's certain requirements that
the leaders think that people need Upon
finishing basic training
your mistress
your concubine perhaps the only thing in
life you'll ever truly love that's one
of those things again that you get from
TV in Hollywood where we placed all of
this level of intimacy with our weapon
now granted it is an intimate
relationship because you really want to
be confident with that weapon so taking
it apart putting it together almost to
the point you can do it blindfolded
right talk about it in a way that might
be sexual that's kind of a Hollywood
thing that happens I'm sorry sergeant
I can't touch a gun for that time period
being World War II being a conscientious
objector was going to definitely be a
challenge for the leadership here this
guy particularly is uh Desmond Doss he
was actually a Medal of Honor recipient
and he didn't have to carry a weapon to
do it I would definitely say this was a
nine on realism I can't think what I'm
giving you a few love Taps how the are
you going to fire your rifle when
grenades are going off in your face
you know unfortunately what we wind up
running into a lot of times is drill
sergeants or Di's like this one that
will touch and grab by the throat that
was familiar and other you know di
movies touching recruits and in uh
training is unacceptable always has been
sir
that's exactly why right there the open
door that I could do even more when it
turns to him slamming the kids head into
a wall and and that's why it's
unacceptable because where do you draw
the line them paintball bullets they
hurt
well paintball is something as you
noticed there was pretty painful that
guy uh is going to learn a valuable
lesson not to put himself in a window if
he's going to engage and so that that's
why paintball uh simunitions is kind of
what we call it is very very useful in
the training environment
[Music]
get the fear out of you
yeah that's a trainer a sergeant a
Leader's worst nightmare is to have
somebody in training uh lose their life
shooting the rounds over their head we
actually do that and we also do it at
night but the conditions are totally
different the guns are are raised up a
whole lot higher as and it's what we
call a a safe surface zone so even if
you stood up or jumped up and down it's
almost 20 feet above the heads of the
individuals and again this tragedy right
here as unfortunate as it is it does
happen when those things are not adhered
to for a boot camp movie it's probably
about a five
Rusty bayonet leap God
now thanks to these men and their
infractions every man in the company who
had a weekend pass has lost it this is
pretty neat because I actually served as
the command sergeant major for this unit
for the second Battalion 506 parachute
Infantry Regiment out at 101st Airborne
this right here is easy company and
their preparation for World War II
during that time period in our military
not many people were married right and
everybody was always looking for a
two-day or three-day pass the stuff that
they're being inspected on like it's
parade level stuff and they're out there
in combat gear I could see where he's
going but trying to instill discipline
just uh I'm sure morale is not going to
be too high much longer
do not help that man do not help that
man we ran this mountain a couple of
times Curry heat Mountain yeah it's no
joke uh what I noticed here though you
know he was telling him to leave that
guy not leaving uh our fallen comrade
you know that's a part of the warrior
ethos and never quitting so when you tie
that together in today's modern military
uh leaving somebody behind would be
something that we wouldn't do that would
be a 10 for running up that hill and for
World War II uh it'd probably be about
an eight in realism
you get them in the barber chair spin
them around they had no hair like that's
even part of like a military Cadence
sometimes or males anyway are getting
their hair cut where they cut it all the
way down female recruits are not
required and believe it or not it's a
health and hygiene issue right because
you get people that come from all walks
of life and so you don't know
necessarily if they have like headlights
or any other type of issues underneath
all the hairs that you got about a
hundred shots
you just get shots until you get all the
way to the end and you're completely
inoculated against every disease known
to man right
execute
the difference that I could see so far
in this scene is they have them all
taking their clothes off like in an open
room or an open Bay it wouldn't be done
that way at the what they call a
military entrance processing station or
the MEPS all military members go through
there and there's no drill sergeants
there right it's it's just a staff of
military personnel administrators
doctors counselors because what they're
doing is they're determining whether or
not you're fit to train
how to strip down to our underwear and
duck walked a circuit of a big room
oh yeah duck walking I remember the
first time I did that I was like what in
the world they have you walk from one
side of the room to the other and the
doctor is looking for your bone
structure your musculoskeletal uh
development if you're flat-footed also
just your mobility and Agility but yeah
you definitely wouldn't be in a room
like that full of other people be hard
to assess I would have to say it's about
a four right because that's not
necessarily how that whole
indoctrination process would happen with
the drill sergeants
survive recruit training it will be a
weapon you will be a minister of death
praying for war so far this is looking
pretty good it's in the Di's in the
Marine Corps they actually have a script
they say you'll sit up straight and look
at me so while the difference in the
titles the drill instructors was tied
into the Marine Corps drill sergeants
became into play for the Army and the
interaction in the first part of boot
camp is always going to be what we call
Total Control everywhere you look
there's going to be some di or drill
sergeant ensuring that the training that
has been given is being reinforced and
so when you see uh our Lee Army walking
around in the bay he's doing exactly
what a DI would do he actually was a
drill sergeant as a matter of fact he
served several years during the Vietnam
War as a
diagnets understand that
I can't hear you
[Applause]
if you notice the DI is constantly
yelling and it's not because they like
yelling at individuals it's just said
they don't have to repeat the same
commands over and over so if you have a
recruit on one end of the bay uh he or
she is going to hear the instructions
all the way on the other end of the Bay
no and I didn't know they stuck that
high you trying to squeeze the niche in
on me somewhere huh another thing that
you often see in these movies and TV
shows is the DI or the drill sergeant
doing a lot of cursing and swearing
cursing and swearing is not something
that is acceptable but but it does
happen for that Vietnam era that's
pretty realistic now you have people who
are deciding to you know serve their
country and it's a different view I was
part of the committee that created the
change what we call shock and awe
commonly called a shark attack as
opposed to this fallacy which was we
have to break them down in order to
build them up and focus more on the
teamwork and so that's what the hundred
yards was designed to do day one here's
a challenge
mm-hmm
part of that indoctrination when the DI
comes in says the wellness of the
trainees or the recruits and so they
have to inspect the feet and inspect
their hands and make sure that there's
no open source
what is that private pile sorry jelly
donuts sir we've gone away from Foot
Lockers and uh modularized most of the
equipment in the base so you wouldn't
necessarily have a Foot Locker in the
bay and it definitely wouldn't be
standing on the equipment like that they
have this term in the army they call
Total Line and that's where they
actually stand next to the line so that
they can do that inspection from now on
the ever private pile
I will not punish him I will punish all
of you
yep there we go
especially in the beginning phases of
boot camp the DI and the drill sergeant
is going to definitely Dole out
punishment as a mass punishment even
though one person may mess up this
opportunity for somebody to have looked
and held pile accountable for that donut
was missed and that's what the DI is
reinforcing will hold each other
accountable I would have to say it was
probably about a nine for that era uh if
we're talking in today's terms it'd
probably be about a seven in realism we
are going to win this war because we
have the best men
when he was standing formation and the
leader stopped and kind of looked at
this guy he looks like a middle middle
school kid that was actually a guy named
uh Flaherty this guy was four feet nine
inches and they called him the Giant
Killer because of all the different
exploits that he did during Vietnam and
he was small and then Rogers was right
everybody's got that flag in 17 years
all right
yo the smallest guy right in the
formation wound up coming up with the
plan of success in the basic training
environment you probably wouldn't have
that type of situation placed on a
trainee or recruit that's some special
missions type units uh stuff that's
going on there where an assessment is
being done right because they want to
know if you have a special skill set
what they were actually doing in the
training would not necessarily be
something that you would see in recruit
training so I'm gonna give it a five
thanks
yeah that's the campaign hat or the the
famous drill sergeant hat I just
happened to have mine with me and uh you
know this distinct Tech here that is
worn by the male drill sergeants in the
Army
um but then also by the male and female
diss in the Marines what's unique is
while all the branches except the Navy
has some form of a campaign hat
um the Army still has a separate hat for
the female drill sergeant it's called a
bush hat hello hello
[Music]
that part where the one character starts
singing that you know Diddy Bop is
interested in that most cadences that's
actually where they come from right
popular Tunes R B music I mean even
nursery rhymes even my own voice has
been tapped into with cadence and the
Gatorade commercial singing the hard
work Cadence
so these guys they're just you know
jumping in on a bandwagon throwing in
the Ditty Bop in there at the same time
one two three four
five two three yeah that ain't happening
however uh in the Army in what we call
the advanced individual training which
those periods of training go from six
weeks to six months maybe even a year
drilling ceremony competitions are
usually used to continue to motivate
those individuals that have the longer
periods of training but not as likely in
a basic combat training because we're
focusing on shooting moving
communicating and treating yourself and
others on the battlefield I'd have to
say a four
represented by dummy you must then
transport him to the emergency field
Hospital there's a lot going on there so
far when it started out it definitely
was something that you would see in
recruit training you know a lot of
female leaders now are in positions of
senior leadership uh that something that
hadn't occurred over many years until
the military had started really opening
up the ranks of the Infantry to our
female leaders
an aggressor team will be trying to stop
you they are all awaiting ranger
training and can't wait to capture you
based on what the information and the
instructions they were given is actually
an advanced individual training you know
medical training they're not going to be
as complex with a mission that would go
that deep and that was evident when I
saw them in the river there because the
risk for you know perhaps somebody
drowning or you know something else with
all that equipment on and not too many
people are going to want to put a
recruit in that type of environment
thank you
again the risk factors wouldn't be
something that you'd see in recruit
training but definitely something very
similar challenging wise as far as the
military is concerned you know Marines
have a crucible and the Army has this
thing called the forge very similar in
the final test of all of the training
that they received during the recruit
training and the medical Lanes where
they might have to treat a casualty or
transport a casualty like you saw here
to really see if all of the training has
actually reached uh the point where they
are confident that these individuals can
leave and go to their next assignment I
have to give that a five as far as
realism
foreign
is something that again has never been
uh accepted but uh it happens this is
depicting an environment where there's
still initial entry training or initial
military training but it's officer
candidate School typically officer
candidates are a little bit more mature
uh have either been in the military for
quite some time and reached enlisted
ranks there's levels of hazing that may
be more acceptable uh in that
environment versus in the recruit
training so there was a mandate that
provided leadership across all of the
branches so come up with you know
Progressive ways if you would in order
to attack and get in front of hazing and
so whether it was uh reporting such as
in the Army you know not my squad to
place accountability not just on
leadership but on each other
two or three layers of checks and
balances so that you don't have that
Rogue di or Rogue drill sergeant who
might take something personal like it
looks like in this clip because of the
flexibility and the things that take
place in the office of candidate School
versus what happens in recruit training
for initial entry training I would say
uh that is a probably about a seven
all right surely you can drop them now
weight training has always been
something that's important in the
military to be able to carry your body
weight and in some cases you might have
to lift or carry or drag somebody else
the sand buckets and them using them for
weights a lot less expensive than buying
weights for every Marine but then they
get the same physical exercise out of it
to the body once again
okay
you know they were doing combatives
right with the pugils and and then the
drill instructor was showing them with
the knife close quarter combat because
every Marine every Soldier every person
that joins the military is is a fighter
first right and so pugal training is one
of those ways that that confidence is
instilled in the individual uh in their
ability to stand their ground and it's
also fun to look at
I would say it's a about a seven my
favorite drill instructor was uh Jack
Webb and the movie The di it actually
shows both sides of the drill
instructor's life what does he do in the
evenings after he's away from the base
Squad if you enjoyed this video why not
click on this video above